we're not talking about a peace deal
we're talking about a ceasefire and
those are actually two very really
important things um I think uh a
ceasefire is something that Putin has
reportedly and uh uh I know personally
the reporters that worked on this for
the New York Times who reported it on
23rd of December and they have very good
sources and uh uh their information is
that there have been unofficial back
Channel feelers from the Kremlin to uh
senior officials in Washington to
discuss the possibility of a ceasefire
ceasefire not necessarily a peace deal
but a ceasefire um essentially freezing
the conflicts along the line of control
and uh I find that uh pretty plausible
actually because um that kind of deal um
that kind of arrangement that kind of
ceasefire allows Putin to sort of lock
in a situation on the ground that he
hopes is going to become a de facto
eventual partition of Ukraine